two
[Music]
welcome everybody to the second annual
steamies
it's
2022. we are here it's the steamies
well it's been a huge year
lots of categories in fact we've had
more votes this year
on our categories
three times more votes than last year
that's right totaling
100 000 votes we got
is that right ian
yeah 100 000 votes the people are
activated they are ready to engage
well
well guys last year as you know i had a
co-host for the steamies
uh trisha paytas who by the way is
excluded but from all categories i'm
sure it would have been a full sweep
but we had to exclude her for reasons
that are known and unknown
uh
a little cryptic at the gate there but
what can you do uh we do have a guest
though
one that uh is beloved in the community
one that reports the facts the news the
gossip and all the drama and all that
with a cup of noodles it's the one the
only dennis death noodle
[Applause]
there you go
hello
well thank you for having me this is
crazy it's an honor to be sitting here
with you today
to uh present the drama of the year and
who better who better who better yeah oh
well it's an honor to be wearing a tux
for the first time in like five years to
be you actually look good in yours
unlike me
so you you look good he's very tall by
the way you guys might not know how tall
are you six four six four yeah oh we
gotta get you to go back back with zach
and see his thoughts you really wanna
no no no no not today today we celebrate
today we celebrate ethan who are
the sponsors of the steamies today the
sponsors are dr sasquash
i mean sasquatch
sasquatch
sasquatch okay
dr sasquatch and masterclass thank you
thank you
dennis
how are you feeling
feeling pretty good i mean it's
i don't know if i can bring the same
energy that trisha brought but
yeah he's gonna be you can't hey you
can't reply listen you just be yourself
okay
nobody can nobody can replace that that
kind of energy yeah
well
yes laughter
tears
how are you feeling what what category
are you most excited for this year uh
the what was the one that i almost
murdered your friend or something yeah
we have a new category this year called
biggest
this feels illegal
but for some reason nobody faced
consequences awards oh yeah that one's
that's a good category
no that that's a good one i want to know
one that one but that's an attempt at
murdering your friend award yeah they're
all really exciting yeah fantastic stuff
yeah
it's good category how's the channel
doing how's everything doing you're
banned on twitter that's been a huge
controversy yeah yeah i've been on
twitter thanks to [ __ ] can i say yeah
all right all right good good so yeah
thanks the [ __ ] keemstar i think
sorry my opinion it's my opinion
yeah keemstar's been around long enough
he's like he he definitely knows how to
mass report and do all that the negans
boy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that keemstar guy right [ __ ]
that keemstar guy yeah what a piece of
[ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] right uh now but plus he
has like contacts at twitter that's why
i feel like
you know he's pulling some strings
i can't imagine that guy having contacts
anywhere i mean uh he would want to
associate with that guy but there it is
there it is
well what do you say we jump right into
it dennis yeah let's do it
all right
well
our first category
it's huge huge category some old some
new
uh
biggest cove idiot
now this is a legacy category
last year the winner was jake paul
deserved
this year i think yeah round of applause
for jake paul
this year actually jake isn't even
nominated uh the the biggest uh well how
do you wanna do this do you play it and
then or do i yeah why don't we uh take a
look at the nominees okay so are you
gonna yeah okay go ahead
biggest co-video
[Music]
chat hangs in a new instagram video the
eldest son of the hollywood couple
shared his anti-vac stance i got the
vaccine
i think everybody should i think it's
really important like that we all do
this just as like citizens as americans
we have to look out for each other and
get under control guys psychic
if it ain't broke don't fix it i never
had covert yay sticking me with that
[ __ ] needle it's the
[ __ ] flu joe rogan
there's uproar today over joe rogan's
advice to young americans not to get
vaccinated if you're like 21 years old
and you say to me should i get
vaccinated i'll go no if you're a
healthy person and you're exercising all
the time and you're young and you're
eating well like i don't think you need
to worry about this and turns out i got
coveted
so we immediately threw the kitchen sink
out of all kinds of meds monoclonal
antibodies ivermectin prednisone z-pack
nad drip vitamin drip everything a
wonderful heartfelt thank you to modern
medicine i'm not a doctor i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] should impedance oh
here's the deal guys i'll get the
vaccine you [ __ ] leave me alone okay
get the vaccine then if you're not gonna
leave me alone why are they vaccinated
all of a sudden the unvaccinated all of
a sudden a danger i suspect that
that medicine independent of public
health kills more people than it saves
nikki
on monday the new confirmed
that she would not be attending this
year's med gala because of the event's
vaccination mandate my cousin in
trinidad won't get the vaccine because
his friend got it and became impotent
his testicles became swollen his friend
was weeks away from getting married now
the girl called off the wedding so just
pray on it and make sure you're
comfortable with your decision not
bullying that rapper nicki minaj who
turned out to be one of the bravest
people in the united states are you
kidding me
tucker carlson
wow
well what do you think dennis stiff
stiff uh competitors there yeah i'm
thinking i mean honestly i think joe
rogan's got this one joe rogan
definitely he's got the reach he's got
the he's got everything wrong yeah and
he's so confident yeah uh i feel like
it's got to be joe rogan but there's
such strong entries there let's not
overlook nicki minaj's uh friend
cousin's friend oh yeah who's testicles
[Laughter]
you know
as all good relationships uh i know elo
would have left me if my testicles
swollen swell swole on our wedding day
she would yeah no way
jose
by by the way why was jordan peterson so
angry in that clip you notice it yeah
he's very upset about he's become very
angry yeah actually but
he's he's become very upset about the
the covet thing although he just seems
angry in general
i don't know
good observation yeah well
i think we know who's it gonna be i
think yeah i have a is this it do i grab
the card okay okay so we're opening do
you want to do the honors here let's see
here you you go ahead you go ahead okay
and then you guys we have the uh
drum roll please biggest cove idiot
20 21
wow with 21 percent
joe sorry sorry 81
a huge majority goes to joe
rogan
congratulations joe this is beautiful
look at this nice steaming hot cup of
joe just for you do not drink this
whatever's going on in there certainly
not for conception although let's be
frank it's probably safer than the other
stuff he puts in his body yeah i mean
you know he's taken off her brain why
not just take a sip of this right you
want to try it uh yay
cheers doctor i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't do that don't even sniff it well
maybe it's just
yeah why is it what what is happening
it's dry ice
ghost in the ghostbusters
the ectoplasm yeah it's like growing do
we need a fire extinguisher no it's dry
yeah so i think we'll be okay on the
fire hazard side of things
well
this is exciting joe rogan with 81
percent
nicki minaj with eight percent came in
second the cousin's story was a was a
real that was a really good moment of
the year yeah doesn't won
you got big balls but didn't win it yeah
that's a shame yeah
well
congratulations to joe
um
fantastic stuff
you know
pretty exciting category yeah
yeah have you been hearing about the
drama um
what was willie who's the guy who pulled
his music not willie nelson uh oh neil
young young yeah young music he pulled
all his music today yeah i saw that
i think it's funny how all the
conservatives are like this dude really
thought uh spotify was gonna drop joe i
don't think he ever thought that i think
he's just making a conscientious no yeah
100 yeah um i was listening to tim paul
talk about it obviously he had the worst
uh the worst reaction ever i mean
i don't know i i just think it's
you can't get away with putting out that
much [ __ ] without some kind of
you know what i mean well certainly
again it's like
if we're going to talk about freedom the
man's got a freedom to make a stand and
we're right folks you understand and i
and here i'm announcing today that i
will be pulling all of our podcasts off
no we're not doing that
i mean
no
right no
we're not making a stand here today
folks
thank you
shout out to the uh
wonderful
uh
i mean maybe we can but let's maybe not
a snap decision in the middle oh i was
gonna say i'm pulling i'm not pulling
folks
not today
thank you
um
next up
huge award huge category spiciest drama
yeah last year toddy versus jeffrey
that one winner yeah
tati is she really knows how to spice
things up doesn't she yeah and uh i
think for the last like two years she
was just
going away for a while and coming back
and dropping a massive video yeah
really serious accusations
yeah but she was kind of silent this
last year wasn't she yeah so i don't
even think she was nominated but boy we
have a lot of categories here
uh let me read them off here or well go
ahead and play uh for spiciest drama
let's take a look at our nominations
spiciest drama
[Music]
creepshow art exposed
one very recognizable source my stalker
is shannon better known as creepshow art
and what i believe to be her current
husband anthony parker and shannon
anthony if you're watching this you have
no idea what you guys have done to me
she suffered as far as i understand it
the greatest percentage lost of
subscribers of any cancellation ever
it's over
i am done i am not coming back to
youtube and to everyone else go touch
some [ __ ] graphs i am done
i am [ __ ] done bad baby first doctor
oh yeah the whole dr phil show is they
send these kids to either turnabout or
these other programs that are also in
utah but they're all wilderness programs
and they're all [ __ ] up the abuse the
the malnourishing physical abuse mental
abuse
all that and this place is still up and
running if she had a bad experience you
know obviously i would i would hate that
we'd be sorry about that this ranch is
still listed on your website after a
lawsuit about a murder a lawsuit about
sexual abuse and a lawsuit about torture
we're not involved in that we don't have
any feedback from them he just said he's
not involved in any treatment facility i
go to are you [ __ ] nuts ace family
lost their house okay kathleen there's a
lot of rumors that uh your house is
getting foreclosed what do you have to
say about that it's not true it's not
true last month their double mansion was
put on auction for nine million dollars
apparently the contractor on the job
wasn't even a real contractor they went
into escrow without getting a
certificate of occupancy t-channel
nobodies that have been making videos
about us and talking about us in a
negative light it's because they make
money off of us and they're using you
stop counting my money count my
blessings
hassan pika owning a house a massive
amount of pushback and backlash because
it came out that he had purchased a 3
800 square foot home in west hollywood
for 2.74 million dollars i am once again
under the crossfires being mercilessly
ripped apart by you know the greatest
activists of all time anarchists on
twitter twitch gambling exposed as a
scam gambling ain't a thing to make
money on if you think you're gonna make
money gambling you're a [ __ ] idiot
don't [ __ ] be dumb [ __ ]
don't be dumb you
not this is their address you guys
britney's fight to end the
conservatorship
britney spears broke down in tears at a
hearing today over control of her life
and fortune much of her life has been
controlled in recent years by her father
and a professional conservator after
nearly 14 years it took a judge in this
courthouse today less than 40 minutes to
decide that britney spears
conservatorship was no longer required
for most ardent fans the legions of the
free britney movement celebrating
outside guys uh seems brittany is free
really
thank you guys
the ending of frenemies
david dobrik in the vlog squads meltdown
for that documentary going clear about
scientology
yeah
so our show turned into the going clear
vlog squad
okay ethan i'm sorry to my family and
i'm sorry to my friends that i'm
embarrassed and that this won't happen
again
wow
what nomination is this yeah definitely
all together you realize what a big year
it's been huh yeah
it's uh
some big names
who do you think's gonna take to dub i
really can't decide spiciest drama
i i don't know i think the vlog squads
got this oh really yeah honestly that
was a that was a pretty big one but when
you look back at the i mean hassan [ __ ]
buying a house was probably oh yeah that
too in my opinion yeah that was great
unforgivable i feel like you're
overlooking a pretty big one there um
the ending of frenemies
that's true
that was a pretty good one yeah this was
the only time we were allowed to mention
uh trisha only by proxy so oh you could
even i just noticed you didn't show her
in the footage that's right we didn't
even show on the footage it's wild wow
that is wild isn't it
well the twitch gambling the david
dobrik one was huge
i gotta give it up to bad baby who
brought the heat to dr phil oh yeah that
was good that was you know i'm not a fan
of his now i'm a fan of hers yeah for
doing that me too yeah yeah she really
brought the heat to mr potato head yeah
uh well brittany too i mean britney
spears she's free for pete's sake yeah
and it's still going on right up until
like a couple of weeks a week or so ago
i think it's pretty much done at this
point i mean she's posting her nudes to
instagram she is free yeah literally and
figuratively i meant the beef between
her and her sister oh yeah it's been
going on still
yeah well i think we'll be hearing about
the brittany stuff for for years to come
but dennis would you like to do us the
honors here of course yeah spiciest
spiciest drama wow wow
so let's see who won
uh oh wow with 69 percent of the uh the
votes
wow
the ending of frenemies
who could have seen that one coming in
away this one this prize is for me is it
not yeah yeah yeah i guess i have to
take a sip uh no no no no no no no
drinking don't do it i'm gonna drink it
uh you gave it to me it's a steam i'm
gonna drink it don't do that
oh it's mine well let's get this out to
trisha to congratulate her yeah because
obviously you know takes two to tango
yeah and uh so we got the runners up
were david dobrik in the vlog squads
meltdown throughout the year there was
nine percent and then britney with eight
percent
yeah what a year man crazy here i gotta
say tati first jeffrey won last year but
these these are bigger dramas yeah it
feels that way well perhaps because you
were involved in well like 75 percent of
them
that's true it was a big year
in the drama sphere wasn't it
well live by the drama die by the drama
that's what they say so thank you
everybody congratulations thank you come
on thank you buddy appreciate that
all right
wow
damn rest in peace uh frenemies huh
we don't talk about it but man that show
was a big deal during during the year
you know oh yeah we were averaging four
or five million views an episode it was
the biggest podcast in the world i think
during that time that whole moment with
jeff the like the gotcha moment i was
watching it back the other day
and it was like
i don't know to me it was like the the
highlight of podcasts like in the year i
think wow thank you so much it was it
was so it was it was so at the same time
was tragic and and funny yeah because he
was clearly lying right the whole time
yeah yeah
and his willingness just to come on the
show without any preparation at all
uh was was fantastic and then there was
that other the other wrinkle was that
uh cat provided me additional evidence
unseen evidence the face of him yeah
where he said he wasn't mm-hmm so that
that's where we got the iconic okay
ethan okay that uh we love so well yep
there it is
it was it was yeah it was crazy thank
you man appreciate it what a year well
coming around
this is exciting this is fun is it not
what a year what a time what a time what
a time to be alive yeah glad to be here
what a joy
well a whole lot i got it yeah let's go
ahead and uh get that over to trisha
thank you
worst apology is the next category last
year's winner was jeffrey starr
and that's going to be one that's going
to be tough to
last year jeffree star made an apology
in his uh
12 mil or like 15 million dollar mansion
and like
in the opulence of his uh
his like louis vuitton couch yeah yeah
well
i'll tell you what again it's like you
look at the nominees this year i feel
like it really dwarfs whatever jeffrey
star did well i don't even remember what
was he apologizing for he was
apologizing for
tati made a video accusing him and shane
dawson
of behind the scenes conspiring against
james charles right yeah right and then
uh yeah that's hard to beat look at this
dude yeah good
what a setting yeah
well um i mean if you look at the
nominees for example the first one here
is travis scott i mean you're talking
the stakes are hot oh yeah much much
higher yeah well let's go ahead and roll
it
worst apology
siename gomez after a month away
i decided to take a month off the
dancing video giving you the negativity
surrounding my platform i know that this
is why god and the universe have given
me this platform i hope this can inspire
you
[Music]
how's this even real
yeah it is pretty incredible i love the
interpretive dance apology
it is uh innovative
[Music]
[Music]
i always make sure that whatever the
video i'm putting out i have the
approval from that person um with the
set situation i'm sorry i missed the
mark with that one yep
yeah with some of the actions i don't
understand how he thought he could get
away with stand for anything he missed
the most conduct and i've been really
disappointed by some of my friends
i speak oh lot louder than words
that's it all right i love you guys
see you later travis scott
anytime i can make out you know anything
that's going on you know you know i
stopped the show and
you know help them get the help they
need you know did anybody figure out why
he was scratching his head i could just
never because he's really he's so
he's so upset
everybody continue to just keep your
prayers
love you all
david delbrick again again
hi guys it's um
1 45
in the morning and
i'm finally by myself
and i've never done this correctly and
i've never done this respectfully a lot
of people reached out to me saying
cancer culture is [ __ ] and you need
to fight back because you need to call
people out probably don't worry about
him i've never done no apology the right
way he's like
james charles holding this one's good
too especially considering he kept doing
it many of you guys know about two years
ago now i was involved with a very
public online scandal uh when this first
happened two years ago i uploaded a
video to my channel called no more lies
i'm sorry too i forgot how
when i upload this tomorrow it is going
to be april fool's day awful time
please
please do not believe what you're
hearing online so this is the truth all
right what actually upsets me the most
is that anybody else was hurt
on
he then abused that trust to go and
alter the code resulting in six figure
profits for him and then leaving the
rest of us to be blamed
awesome
wow what
i can't honestly
i have some guesses here i mean astro
world probably the highest stakes
apology to worst apology ratio yeah you
know
uh
james charles obviously again holding
myself accountable he's still doing it
right that's yeah that's been shown and
also you have the added element of him
just going in there and admitting to two
of them right and calling them victims
right in the middle of the the apology
right
which is a crime right he's admitted to
a crime yeah and then he erased the
apology and erased it awesome and then
he's a new one where he whitewashed yeah
and then blamed everybody for like you
know what a guy huh we love james
charles around here yeah
if i had to guess though oh god there's
some really good apologies here i'm
gonna guess
travis scott just because the stakes are
so high yeah the black and white yeah
you know
now let's take a look yes i think it's
travis scott too yeah okay
worse apology
2021
the votes have been cast the people have
spoken
47
and the winner is
travis scott
of astroworld
one and only
yeah it's lit
wow
uh and and a runner up james charles 31
and oh sienna
gomez the dance video 10
david dobrik totally forgotten sounds
like the uh closest category so far yeah
but that's a huge dub for for travis
scott obviously
a bunch of fatalities and
how how do you think sienna was like
what do you think she was thinking of
when she was choreographing that dance
like
i think she thought shh i think a lot
enough people were like on her side
publicly like big people that she
thought it was i don't think it was an
apology necessarily more like i am
powerful i will not be i will not be
slandered all my friends have my back
like dave pork boy and a bun a huge bun
tana mogo yeah joe had her how do you
say her last name mojo okay yeah
it's a lot of letters mojo mojo jojo mo
uh
so i think she thought it was a dub
and uh well she hit the runner up so
yeah and that was stiff competition so
shout out
travis scott
this one's for you my friend
[Applause]
very good maybe the last award he ever
gets
yeah that's true
yeah that's a that's a full-on
cancellation huh you think travis scott
will ever make it back into the
limelight uh i think yeah i think they i
think pretty soon he's going to make it
back i mean the the
you know the whole thing with kanye
trying to go to his daughter's birthday
and kim kardashian not letting him so
that like a lot of people who follow the
kardashians we're speculating that
part of the reason why kanye said
publicly that travis scott is the one
who gave him the address to to find the
party was because chris jenner was
trying to
make it make him seem a little more like
a nice guy yeah like start
rehabilitating his image uh i'm afraid
you're right i think i think he's gonna
be back before too long yeah probably in
a few years most people will just forget
and that's the way it goes eh
what's a few what's a few
fatalities and uh oh yeah and the scheme
of things right yeah
oh
well moving on
oh here we have an update travis scott
fans are pushing hard from the headline
next year's coachella and even have a
petition going to get him on the stage
next year they don't want him in they
want a headline the big comeback
i don't see that happening necessarily
but uh who knows yeah the crazy world we
live in isn't it yeah maybe he'll run
for president
yeah well i wouldn't be surprised
up next we have most frivolous lawsuit
this is a really uh
stiff competition yeah four entries all
powerful
anyone could take it
go ahead let's see it
most frivolous lawsuits
trilovus ethan klein copyright free
speech is under attack
fair use is under attack
this is a serious message with peace and
love peace and love truly ethan klein
how many cautious interference it's very
right our right to exist on youtube is
under attack by ryan chilly this ethan
klein website cyber squad this is the
third lawsuit against me
by an elite
hollywood executive
merely for exercising my
free speech my right to have an opinion
ryan cavanaugh versus ethan klein
defamation he's seeking to destroy me to
de-platform me to bankrupt me this is
not a drill
well
what do you think one two three or four
i think the most the fourth one was
where the website won right that was the
third one actually that was the third
squatting yeah the cyber squatting to me
that one was just absolutely ridiculous
well that one doesn't even make sense
like it doesn't even make sense actually
speaking of which since we're on the
topic if you guys go ahead into google
and type ryan kavanagh you're going to
see
our website is number one
really yeah number one
i mean google
google recognize you know good websites
and information when they see it if you
guys want to type ryan kavanagh on the
search bar and go ahead and click this
honestly if i were him i'd be grateful
so that nobody confuses him that's what
i'm saying
it's a public service what could he be
mad about i mean spend some time on the
website educate yourself play the game i
mean look at the the the
resemblance is uncanny they look so
similar yeah
um here you can just play the game read
up about him so yeah highly recommend
you guys do that thank you
thank you so by the way
yeah just an added thing i think he
should be
did you see this clip uh mike tyson was
on the knuck boys
and he said he still hasn't been fully
paid for his trailer fight yeah yeah
yeah shouldn't he be more worried about
paying mike tyson instead of suing you
like all this money off the lawyers well
to be honest with you i don't think he
has much money to pay out he probably
owes mike like tens of millions yeah
imagine yeah and the lawsuits is
probably costing him maybe the hope is
the money he gets from you
i think you know what you call that when
you get money from one person to pay
another oh
there is a term for that isn't it it's
some sort of scheme oh yeah that's right
not that he's runs upon no no we would
never we would never make right
kavanaugh does not run a ponzi scheme
that i'm aware of
right now
how would i know
uh so
go ahead do us the honors dance most
frivolous lawsuits let's see one two
three
four four
let's see
it's exciting
so ryan cavanaugh versus ethan klein
defamation with 46 percent
thank you ryan oh we need yep here's a
cup of tea for ryan cavanaugh
technically is that for you
is it for me it's at least a shared
trophy with uh oh yeah yeah yeah so it
makes sense well i don't want to hang
out with you so you can have the reward
46
and then the cyber squatting at 22 and
then copyright infringement with 18.
beautiful yeah too much wine sorry yeah
too much wine you had too much wine what
did you say about natalie portman
again have an inappropriate relationship
with the 14 year old natalie department
oh what why is he saying that i mean
that is just disgusting
awful
that's the only reason i came yeah yeah
well anyways uh congratulations to ryan
well deserved well deserved yeah
um we're at a
uh 30 minutes so i think it's time to
throw all right well we've got two
sponsors to thank real fast and when we
come back you guys aren't going to want
to miss we have the best categories
coming up it's a whole
thrill ride we'll be right back
all right ready
dr squatch is here to help save you from
that body wash that's packed with harsh
harmful chemicals and those garbage
personal care products you're used to
they're changing the game with high
performance natural products that smell
amazing they really do these things
smell amazing and we'll have you feeling
them looking your best
nope don't eat soap
dr swatch will take your shower game to
the next level helping you level up your
soap and step up your scent choose your
favorite line of soaps hair care
deodorants and more so you never have to
have another boring shower or routine
again what is this
oh deodorant nice
hmm
nice
dr squash's soaps are made in the united
states using only the finest ingredients
mother nature has to offer plus they're
transparent about their ingredients and
their production seriously go ahead and
take a look at the label you'll
recognize everything you're there that's
there
wow i do recognize everything seriously
go ahead and take a look at the label uh
feel free to compare this with what's in
the soap you're using and see if you can
recognize any of those ingredients
whether you're looking for a gift for
your partner or you want to step up your
own routine dr squash has you covered
with a range of fresh scents everyone
will love and just like the ingredients
in their products all their scents are
natural too so ditch those fake smelling
products and go with what smells awesome
nature
are you ready to start taking your
routine seriously with better natural
products get rid of those fake smelling
body washes aluminum filled
antiperspirants and hair care products
that are probably doing more harm than
good with dr squash you can get the
natural clean products you want without
the extra trendy clean markup you're
used to dan actually you use this
product eh i do my my girlfriend uh
stepped up my soap game for me um i
can't be relied upon to do that myself
and uh i've been using it for a while
now i got i'm on that gold moss uh this
one you got the bar soap the bar soap
yeah i don't have too much use for the
shampoo although i do i do use a beard
shampoo but um do you wash your head
with bar soap how does that work
no should i be well do you wash your
head i mean yeah but well yeah i mean i
guess i do because you know i do this
and then you can do it all over so yeah
yeah i guess i do yeah just scariest
yeah
it smells really good this is the cold
brew cleanse coffee
oh wow i like that one
nice do you use it spar soap or any of
the other ones i use the bar soap yeah
and uh do you use the deodorant uh yep
interesting was it was it and i smell
great you do smell great was allie
trying to tell you something when she
bought you all this [ __ ] she's like you
stinky ass get the squatch
watch
now new customers get 20 off orders of
20 or more use our code dsqh3
and click the link in the description
you can get that code in the description
dsqh3
uh oh i guess it stands for discount h
man ever it's in the description doctor
squash doc oh doc
in the description twenty percent off
orders weren't twenty bucks thank you dr
squatch
thank you to masterclass i'm super
excited to be working with masterclass
this is such a cool company
uh with such an amazing offer here
with masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace gordon ramsay for
example has all these cooking recipes
with basics
with specific
recipes he's doing lessons on how to
cook restaurant quality food at home
amazing so cool i love cooking i've
taken a few of these courses it's really
great really fun
and um it's kind of hard to believe that
they're able to get such huge names here
to teach the other one look at this
they've got ringo's freaking star
teaching how to drum
click the trailer let me see that let me
does he start with the peace and love
let's see
[Applause]
well if you want to stay inspired
[Applause]
[Music]
open your eyes
oh
open your eyes folks
no
it's ringo come on peace and love also
martin score stacy teaching um
film yeah that's awesome
how do they get these people man
wow
well it's really cool
uh i take i took the and then zach was
super excited about carlos uh sam
santana santana
he's the
the wicked woman guy black magic woman
black magic woman yeah yeah he shreds
apparently right zach amazing guitar
player yeah
pretty cool
so
get in there and learn some cool stuff
man there's so many options check it out
with unlimited access to every master
class
and as a listener of our show you get 15
off an annual membership
go to masterclass.com
after dark now that's masterclass.com
after dark for 15 off master class
incredible
super exciting amazing stuff get in
there guys and freaking learn something
for christ's sake
welcome back
it's the steamies
bringing you the juiciest
drama and awards of the last year 2021
joined with deaf noodles welcome back
everybody welcome back uh moving on to
our next category
worst influencer song
now this is a fun category and let me
tell you
[Applause]
uh wait
last year
last year the winner was one day one day
yeah really really really really really
sad by dixie dimillio
uh this year we have some good i feel
like we're the heyday of influencer
music is a little behind us that every
day bro yeah i do miss those days a bit
yeah
uh it it feels like uh
i i i mean
some are some influencers are still
trying but i feel like the majority of
them have just like
maybe settled with just accepting that
they're not musicians yeah yeah that's
not good but man those were the days
well ethan
if you really are um
pining for the days of jake paul uh
songs i have some fantastic news for you
tweeted diss track on dana white just a
few hours ago wow
so maybe we're returning to the glory
days after all
[Applause]
this should be pretty high budget that
should be interesting i'm actually going
to watch this one
he definitely got some ghost writers
probably this time yeah i was going to
say that a lot of people are speculating
that he has ghost riders now or at least
better ghost writers because apparently
nick crompton or whatever wrote the last
the last one so maybe he actually got
real ghost writers this time
no he said that
who nick crompton said he wrote it yeah
really he said he wrote that line that
uh oh he wrote the uh london england is
my city yeah
oh man
wow
well real lyrical genius let's go ahead
and see who our nominees
are worst influences song
[Music]
addison ray
obsessed
oh
of course avoiding um copyright
corpse husband hot demon [ __ ] near
you
was that the actual title
you know people get angry people really
simply corpse but i gotta say
logan paul dink doink ding dong you're
my favorite coin want you to dink on my
face take a drink on my chest yeah yeah
ding donk you're my favorite coin why
don't you come on over take pictures off
you know what's funny about the coins
is that he was straight up scamming
people
and like nobody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
doink is a banger
i'm i i can't lie i'm not i'm not super
familiar with the other three
you know yeah are you uh the
i remember the addison the corpse one no
i did watch the dream one
um
so yeah but the the ding dong i i mean
that one that's a that's a because
that's a chewing yeah and that comes
with like the package of the scam yeah
so that's a shoe and i gotta say
well let's take a look the winner is
drum roll please
the winner
of worst influencer song
with 59 percent
goes to
logan paul dink doink
[Applause]
[Music]
i love how people say he's like
rehabilitated his image and stuff bro
he's straight up scammed people like a
year less than a year ago yeah like just
actively scammed people
so we liked that for him
uh runners-up include addison ray
obsessed 23 and dream mask sorry dream
uh 12
but uh logan paul tink donk there you go
let's go congratulations logan
yeah congrats we'll have to send that
out by the way i should mention that we
had um
messaged all the nominees
uh every single one of them
probably in the hundreds
yeah um
uh if they wanted to send in a message
or a thank or an acceptance or
acceptance or anything we got zero
responses
well their loss
not a lot of interest this year maybe
next year
oh jake wrote nick crompton's lyrics oh
that's so i had it backwards so actually
jake is the idiot oh but you would think
isn't nip nick crompton english so you
think you would be like i think he would
correct him but yeah when he was on the
when jake was on the podcast years ago
he was telling you that he felt bad
because he wrote the lyrics and
nick didn't want to wrap it but he ended
up doing anyways and then became a meme
glenn is my city rip
should have been like yo jake you know
right okay well we're reacting old drama
[Laughter]
all right well moving on right along
here this is a category that i love
biggest cringe moment oh yeah this is uh
gonna be a great category i can tell
huge entries yeah looking forward to
seeing the nominees let's take a look
yeah
biggest cringe moment
keemstar on aiden ross's stream
[Music]
i'm famous
you're in trouble why oh [ __ ] that
crypto [ __ ]
[Music]
man
that's hard to beat yeah
[Music]
tory lanez he was like saying that i had
like a little dick my dick didn't work
as [ __ ] and he got in trouble with
youtube
what do you think about that
ryan cavanaugh's oh yeah
i mean
ryan sent me a direct message on july
11th
listen to this ship you have been warned
and i will not
be threatened
and maligned and stand by idly
govern yourself accordingly sir
[Music]
right kavanagh yeah wow
uh else stephen crowder panicking
so many great interests do you know that
um the spartans are
that they are like uh
practice man love with children oh oh
there he is oh no sam cedar what a what
what a [ __ ] nightmare
i had no idea this was going to happen
i thought i thought ethan was a stand-up
guy
dream he just he is a
astrophysicist to prove he didn't cheat
and admitted to cheating
one of my speedruns that i did on twitch
has been analyzed by the speedrun.com
volunteer mod team and deemed as
improbable to a degree that is nearly
impossible so lucky in fact that they
came to the mathematical conclusion that
it had 1 in 7.5 trillion odds of
happening i hired a professional
statistician with a phd that is an
active astrophysicist you know that one
odd was him data shows quote no
statistically significant evidence that
dream was modifying the probabilities
here today dream finally admitted to
cheating his 1.16 speedrun and in a
nearly 3 000 word apology claimed that
it was all just an accident he wrote
three thousand word apology and megan
saying it was a mod relationship
you said to me a whole college essay and
i said
i am weed
this is actually maybe the most cringey
for me personally is watching the
kingdom kelly uh perform on the table
that is a good category mike yeah who
are you feeling in there uh i mean
there's so many that stephen crowder
moment is so hilarious and just how much
like
because you know that that he has such a
huge ego and that you just see that man
crumble like in front of you the moment
that he realizes he couldn't hide it and
you see his co-host just like cross in
front of the camera he's like going to
say
you know
yeah he couldn't hide it he crumbled it
was a it was a great moment i think it's
hard it's going to be real hard yeah to
overcome keemstar though because that
stream was just
it was so powerful you could see a
direct correlation between keemstar's
views dropping and that stream yeah yeah
i mean
keemstar everything about keemstar's
existence is cringe that's true
you could just write off the human
himself yeah and put him in the category
exactly
now he's comparing me to hitler
i didn't say that i didn't either why
didn't i say that
well it could go to any one of these i
mean the dream one by itself too i mean
he hired a astrophysicist
to prove
he didn't cheat knowing he cheated i
mean wow that that that's incredible
well go ahead uh okay i believe it's
your turn here this is a big one
this is a big one guys
and
the winner of the steamy is with 54
percent
keemstar adam ross's stream yeah
you know what keemstar
this one's for you my friend
take a nice steaming sip of uh steamy
here
that was hard to overcome
it is yeah
yeah
and i think the best part about all of
it is just watching people's reactions
the way everybody was cool they were
just they they seemed like they wanted
to welcome him and he just turned the
entire room against him from the first
second yeah he was talking about my my
sexual prowess and stuff like uh talk i
mean what a disaster dude don't go hang
out in a room with dudes and talk about
some other dude's penis that's just not
the way it is that's not the vibe stop
keemstar's usually cringe alone but to
see him in a public setting was just
amazing like that oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah runner-ups runner-ups where stephen
crowder were panicking at the sight of
sam cedar with 16 percent and mgk and
megan fox with 12 percent well i am lead
yeah i am i am weed
well congratulations keemstar well well
congratulations well deserved yeah it's
a remind it is a really good reminder
that when you take a guy like keemstar
and you put him in the wild in a real
real life situation then you can realize
actually what up
awful human being he's just he's you
know
he's not cool yeah he's just a cringe
factory he can barely co-exist with
people outside of
the internet yeah that's that's a good
reminder yeah yeah team star shut up
exactly
well moving on uh worst influencer scam
oh wow this was definitely the year of
influencer scams i think with the rise
of of the cryptos and the nfts yeah it's
just been a really good uh profitable
time for them the whole crypto thing
from the get was just it was like a run
for the hills like a gold rush for who
can scam the most people 100
yeah it's i think a gold rush is the
perfect way to put it yeah and uh to
this day nobody's really facing
accountability even to save the kids who
are totally
exposed they're just 100 percent of
fraud uh there's really no repercussions
so um shout out to all those guys who
have you know turned this uh into a
profit with no repercussions yeah that's
the influence your dream right yeah i
guess for some influencers
all right well go ahead with the with
the nominations this is exciting one
worst influencer scam
austin mcbroom
boxing event gladiator battle for bryce
hall's never getting paid
main event youtube superstar don't even
pay the bank for his house are you gonna
pay price yeah
two weeks after the fights went down we
learned yesterday the fighters
themselves have not been paid i can't
believe what i just said and it's a
cardinal sin you don't put on a fighting
event
and forget to um pay the [ __ ]
fighters
logan paul
think
dude there's a whole [ __ ] tribute
or whatever the [ __ ] you think it's like
a spring it's a crypto meme coin and uh
it's [ __ ] it's hilarious it's [ __ ]
hilarious
it's the dumbest cutest [ __ ] i've ever
seen yeah i mean because
if you don't know about crypto [ __ ]
coins like
most of them don't have utility and so
you know dink doing he's literally
describing a scam yeah
no utilities
and not disclosing that he's the
creators yeah in south park style
i'm a ding dong fan it's the dumbest
[ __ ] i ever seen in that one yeah you
made it you really
350 000
ferrari so the winner has been chosen
the guy's address ended up being here
right in l.a how many tickets did you
buy dude i just bought one for all what
one well it came with like 100 or
something right i thought this whole
show was a scam i think it just seems
like a scam because it's too it's it's
it's too epic yeah
it's too good to be true face
imagine
it turned out to be a scam it was
promoted by some of the biggest
influencers in the world and i support
save the kids tokens save the kids
token save the kids token save the kids
tokens
do not believe what you're hearing
online all of these people making videos
think that they know the truth and that
they know who's responsible i need your
help i know you use your um
so i did something about it i worked
with experts to figure out the best and
safest ingredients for blue light
protection meet reflect it's the skin
care collection that's for everyone who
uses a screen many people were quick to
accuse the brand of being based in
pseudoscience people also began to point
out that the website had some
disclaimers that made things a little
hard to believe like we are not
responsible if information made
available on this site is accurate this
is unbelievable they were like they were
literally saying it is
shaking not actually
shipped
how much do they pay you
as a flat fee every month for fulfilling
your contractual obligations to them
i'll probably get in trouble for
releasing it but i'll tell you a million
a million a month
wow
good money
there's honestly so many
in there i mean
my on my money the biggest scam probably
just on scale and shock factor probably
austin mcbroom oh yeah and because it
was like a whole spectacle
yeah
yeah
and you know austin's kind of a prolific
scammer in his own right mm-hmm
yeah
i mean there is literally video footage
of himself saying
you guys got in reality
he literally admitted to it yeah
well in the context of that one he was
saying you guys got scammed by our
partners yeah yeah yeah
of course yeah never their fault but uh
in terms of you know i mean khalid
dinktonk was good save the kids was a
huge one
the whole thing about like we're doing
this to save the kids and in reality
they're just you know oh yeah
and that's perhaps the most disgusting
one because you're using kids as uh
right
yeah i mean like it's like a comic book
yeah comic book villain yeah yeah like
james bond villain types save the kids
yeah and the one thing that wasn't
conveyed in the nilk one is that the car
was literally parked like one block away
in a parking garage for like a month
leading up to the winner yeah
it made no sense yeah
wow well drum roll
competitive category the winner of
influencer scam
2021
wow
47 percent
the winner is austin mcbroom youtubers
vs tick talkers
yeah congratulations austin he got to be
he he might be you know austin might be
getting scammer of the decade coming up
here you probably yeah yeah 47 percent
uh saved the kids 28 and logan paul dink
doing 16
yeah that sounds about right to me yeah
yep
you know he he had done austin actually
he he's done uh i think two other big
charity events that were just straight
up pocketing the money yeah i think i
heard about a basketball event or
something two of those yeah cheers
cheers
i definitely agree with that yeah just
playing with the dry ice a little bit
there interesting all right
well
that's exciting yeah uh the next one is
a
category of one
uh worst award show oh i wonder i wonder
who that could be worst award show we
were not nominated by the way
oh yeah that's great yeah which is good
news yeah
go ahead and roll the uh nominations
west awards show
the streamies
kids and family the le brandt fam oh my
god
did you watch it this year
no i don't ever watch that [ __ ]
they did it in like a van
the whole award show was in a van
wasn't it and isn't this from it no this
is from other years oh what is the name
that they did in advance they drove
around and handed awards oh no [ __ ] yeah
i mean the people that win this [ __ ] are
so insane
shane dawson
accepting the streaming on his behalf is
tana mojo
[Music]
anna nobody expected to see me here but
what about myself nick huh oh you think
i'm kidding
[Music]
what oh yeah tally shout out to
where are you vitaly garbage love you
bro you should be in prison or might be
in prison yeah i think he may be going
to prison
for unrelated to this this year i became
one of the most hated youtubers on the
platform entertainment that's maybe
because i let ricegum punch me in the
face or maybe because i came out and
said 99 of the pranks on youtube are
fake
but i want to say this look at this one
time i looked at myself in the mirror
and i based myself based on what i read
on the comments i felt worthless i felt
ugly i felt gay i felt
like that just based on what they
thought i felt gay
feels good to actually win something
do you think oh you want a bunch today
about the streamies i mean really
and that's it
i'm really excited to see who wins what
did foose youtube mean when he said i
felt gay
i don't know man he's the only one who
could tell us that yeah
i mean is he i mean
i love that well he was
he was listing off a bunch of um
negative feelings that uh the youtube
comments was making him feel um so it's
a little odd that one of those bad
things is gay yeah so who is he is who
is gay is he gay if you feel gay that
means you want to you ugly have sex with
men if you're a man
no comment there's food make you gay and
that makes him gay if he feels gay i
think so
possibly i don't know
i'm waiting for zach that
oh and i got news for you that means
you're gay oh there it is
well not that there's anything wrong
with that of course just took me off
guard there yeah the steamies by the way
the biggest [ __ ] award show
hey hey
how dare you streamies
thank you
of course we are inspired by the
streamies the steamies and our plan is
to overtake them we were going to get a
big auditorium right uh if trisha didn't
quit like it also is a
fact yeah
we were going to go big this year trisha
ruined everything
uh but that's okay
i don't think anyone would have shown up
for them
uh interestingly the same winners of the
steamies there's a lot of crossover of
the winners of the streamies yep
i noticed that what's that mean
well anyway they didn't nominate us this
year for best podcast despite us you
know being on uh consistently in like
the top 25 in the world
uh so basically the worst award show
by vote 100
the streamies
[Applause]
hundred percent of the vote
[ __ ] the streamies
[ __ ] what enough your award shows
[ __ ] nobody cares nobody watches it
nobody cares [ __ ] you
100 percent
enjoy yeah [ __ ] you guys
your stupid-ass van
have that they did it in a van i
couldn't believe it so what they were
driving in people's houses they were
driving around los angeles in this i i
actually think it was like a double
decker bus or something and it was larae
and his friend who were co-hosting it
and they would just stop and the person
would come out and they were like you
won and they would like pretend like
they were surprised like they didn't
know you know what i mean wow
was it i imagine it was a covert thing
probably yeah yeah yeah
well [ __ ] them
yeah you know what i'm saying
that just sucks dude
well the next one is going to be a big
one the biggest this feels illegal but
for some reason nobody faces consequence
award this is a new award no previous
winners
um
what'd you say abe
nothing i was saying maybe we did win
and swami didn't let them in the gate
oh you think they just tried and swami
just shot the kill
possible swami took him out
you don't think they'd notify me i
wasn't even nominated bro oh that's true
i was just straight up not even
nominated right right we do talk [ __ ]
about them like every year but
yeah well it's not supposed to be biased
based on who likes you or not that's not
what a real award show is right yeah
yeah you defending the story it's
supposed to be
whoever merit yeah exactly
right [ __ ]
i mean everybody talks [ __ ] on award
shows
exactly like jimmy kimmel has a whole
thing with uh the golden globes or what
is it the golden globes or something he
hates one of those award shows he hosts
them he also hosts them yeah
he's
yeah
who cares [ __ ] the streamings
all right
biggest this feels illegal but for some
reason nobody faces consequences award
this is going to be a good one yeah roll
it
biggest this feels illegal but for some
reason nobody faces consequences award
huge new bombshell allegations against
david dobrik and dom ziglitas aka dirty
dog you had insider reporting that a
young woman who was featured in a david
dobrik vlog back in 2018 claimed that
she was by a vlog squad member dirty
dumb the night that they were filming a
vlog for david's channel james charles
has also been recently accused of
inappropriately messaging both young
fans some actually going on to claim
so
that
he
is
that he flirted with a team fan came up
today the alleged james charles
interactions with miners shows a pattern
of jc getting aggressive plus claiming
that the miner lied about their age when
screenshots leaked another one of my
friends came out the video i was a
powerpoint
like passed out on the couch when they
told me about what happened uh they said
they pulled her off of me that night she
posted a 15 part aggressive video
gaslighting everything about what
happened how much she loved me and that
i was using her for clout jake paul
actually just got accused of sexually
assaulting a woman back in the summer of
2019. and the woman who goes by the man
justine paradise on her social media
channels posted 20 minutes
my name's frasier my name's jarvis i'm
chico i'm ricegum oh i recognize these
guys sports save the kids they want to
donate over one million dollars to
charity in 30 days this is gonna be one
of the biggest charity coins ever the
first day it pumps and immediately it
dumps stuff
all the way to negative 90
shout out to the kids in the coin sold
off immediately and why would rice gum
the king of the lambos do anything if
he's not actually involved in some of
the project
you're here to meet a 13 year old this
one's crazy
so what brings you out here today
um whoa i was uh well i was actually
coming out here to pick up a cupcake
yeah and then go back home
wow
that edp one
huge huge yeah
that one might be hard to beat yeah
the there's so many moments from it
there was uh him pounding the guy when
he first met him found it bo yeah we're
good right
yeah the cupcake and then
walking away and they're like following
him you know we never really talked
about edp thing on this show but what
happened was he was chatting up like i
forget how do you remember how old the
girl was she was like 12 or 13. she was
like really young
yeah and he went to meet her for a uh
you know an act
and uh he told them it was done by these
guys who like i guess that's what they
do they're like uh want to be chris
hanson's yeah
and he said i was just coming to get a
cupcake yeah which is awesome yeah yeah
i love that
uh the decoy in his case said she was 13
he said
that 12 year olds are too young and
gross okay so yeah big 12s are gross 13s
are good
according to edp
well i don't know i mean edp is a big
one but david dobrik james charles james
charles was huge this guy is a prolific
predator i mean yeah we're talking about
what in the teens the dozens or over a
dozen there are numerous yeah and uh 16.
and the weird thing about it was that a
lot of their videos would get
immediately taken down right
a lot of the the there was uh that
one of the kids on take like his entire
platform like all of his platforms were
deleted you know i think
face down from like legal threats
probably legal yeah or something sister
sniped sister
i mean you see that a lot too the same
thing happened with people like kevin
spacey
who um
yeah
was notorious for people would accuse
him and then just immediately uh retract
everything and disappear were you trying
to tell me something or die or die
oh yes no a bunch of kevin like
literally multiple of kevin spacey's
accusers died like of weird
circumstances i'm sure that's a
coincidence yeah oh yeah like house of
cards type
he really is that character it's wild
yeah that's why he was so good
actually just being himself
autobiographical mm-hmm well
do the honors let's get a drum roll
please dennis
let's do this
the winner of biggest
feels illegal but for some reason nobody
faced concerts
with 59 percent it is uh james charles
allegedly admits to sexting fighters
congratulations james
that's huge yeah and well deserved
yeah that's actually well deserved thank
you yeah
cheers to you my friend and the irony of
it is less than a month ago there was
another kid who had just turned 18 right
the same thing happened yeah no it's
like it's like he hasn't changed yeah or
like
urges he can't control
uh yet he has a platform and uh he's
changed he's changed in one way he just
keeps getting older and they say the
same age baby oh yeah
uh next one's uh runner-ups are david
dobrik sexual misconduct insider article
details abuse within the vlog squad at
15 and then santa may caught on video as
saying jack wright what 10 percent well
well
wow that's a huge that's just a
resounding victory for
for james or james there yeah
yeah actually uh following up from our
little um kevin spacey
details
um
you sent me something wait i saw
something someone three of kev it was a
cam and yeah three of kevin spacey's
accusers have died that's awesome yeah
out of how many
uh i i don't i've lost track dude
john doe wait john doe that's not his
real name well i think that one was uh
reported anonymously so ari ben three of
kevin spacey's accusers have straight up
died this year well [ __ ] shout out
wow to the king himself kevin spacey you
don't take he don't mess around yeah
they'd play around yeah
uh well
fantastic
fantastic fantastic
jail
no jail that's the
problem no jail for any of them
uh up next is most shameless click bait
good category yeah oh 15 he had 15
accusers
that's what i'm saying yep that's a lot
to usa today i didn't realize kevin
spacey had that many accusers those are
almost james charles numbers
those are james charles numbers he's
scared although james charles is only
what
a third of his age so
yeah
all right
he was about to become uh chairman of
relativity media i know yeah well kevin
spacey yeah he was about to take over
ryan cavanaugh's job are you [ __ ]
kidding me no
for real that awesome
i mean and the other person in
consideration was harvey weinstein but
allegedly by some reports huh so two
great men to replace another great man
and what had the company folded
well no there's no surprise there yeah
yeah
you some might call it a house of cards
yeah oh i see we did there
all right let's see our nominees for
most shameless clickbait
most shameless clickbait
[Music]
jordan cheyenne
we are heartbroken come closer for the
video closer oh no this is so sad act
like you're crying really quick
h3 podcast
we broke up
okay why don't we just do like me and
ela
or breaking up or something like that
we're getting divorced i mean that's
pretty good right we haven't done that
before no we are still together
that vid that podcast got a lot of views
job babe that was it
she said she fell off the mountain
that's ridiculous
i was truly just riddled with anxiety i
had convinced myself that her daughter
had had cancer and it sounds so blunt
and so
almost bad to say but i was convinced
and i kept justifying reasons wait their
daughter didn't have cancer
because of daughter
did you did you follow the story i
didn't follow that one no but i know
they've used their kids for like the
longest time for stuff like so so yeah
they had a video titled
she got diagnosed with cancer still up
still up and then still called that not
cancer in fact they even showed a as a a
child in a hospital bed
yeah here you got to see that and by the
way these are like christian uh
she got cancer
she got diagnosed with cancer look at
this it's still documented that's not
hurt that's not their child
doctor that's a full documentary they
said what is it a parody of a document
how do you they added documentary after
they got in there yeah and i don't think
this was the original the original uh
thumbnail did have their daughter and i
think it was like all the family it
looked like she was dead or something
they made it look like she died someone
said wow
how is adding documentary to the title
though supposed to make it better for
them it's
because they have to explain why the
[ __ ] is he and they're visiting someone
else's kid oh because it's not his kid
huh
yeah pretty incredible right and this
and remind you these are like the good
christian
boys yeah the brands
that one's gotta win that was just
[ __ ] wow wow man
i don't know
yep
hp podcast pretty good runner mail maybe
what do you think let's let's get the
drum roll going
most shameless click bait
2021
the winner
with a resounding 59 percent
goes to the lebron family she got
diagnosed with cancer you can't beat
that yeah you really even you know the
prince family the ace family nobody can
compete with those good god-fearing
christians when they decide to do click
bait they go all the way yeah my child
died of cancer
i mean it says a lot when not even the
ace family would go that far right no
man it does say a lot hey man brother
uh runner up myself h2 podcast we broke
up 27 thank you guys
prince family bianca fell off a mountain
in hawaii while rock climbing
[Laughter]
exactly what happened uh 11 percent
thank you guys what is it what's this
stuff
oh my goodness every video every single
one
well this one i have to say um
you're up for an award my friend oh yeah
oh wow
okay best youtube drama slash news
coverage this one is actually not even
like a diss this is just a straight up
award oh wow
yeah well
i
i'm honored to be
you know
go ahead to be nominated
say more
that's i i don't i don't ever win awards
so i'm like i'm
fine
it's great i mean what else
well the competition is stiff i think
you've got a great chance here i would
say
but let's go ahead and see the uh the
nominees shall we
and this isn't biased nobody knew you
were going to be here
oh yes
[Music]
non-stop like just [ __ ] blatant lies
name one one [ __ ] lie that somebody's
made up about you i'll wait
d'angelo wallace celebrities are out
here trying to give me hope for covert
name team but they all have such a
tremendous lack of taste i'm honestly
more worried about them giving me covet
19 itself
mr beard
did you know that according to tick tock
or siena may if you answered yes that
means you can do whatever you want to
with absolutely no consequences
mysterious
i hate this change the dislike count
went away from me about three or four
days ago and i find it very annoying
because i always like to look at the
like to dislike ratios on every single
video that i watch scarce
hey what's up guys it's scarce here and
our first story of today comes from dr
disrespect so i'm sure you all know at
this point that dr disrespect was one of
the top twitch streamers
rich blocks i don't know how y'all found
out but y'all did it girl jeffrey
starr's
alleged boyfriend has now been exposed
yes adam mcintyre welcome to today's
video
we have the official response from emily
artful
to shannon creep show art it's so ironic
that creeps in her name is like because
she's such a [ __ ] freak
right yeah
well this is our one category
where you know it's not an insult
necessarily it's not an insult at all
this is just pure
um
this is just all love here all right
from the fans
she's
my my my guess would be honestly on deaf
noodles that's who i would that's who
i'm expecting to win obviously d'angelo
wallace is a favorite but i don't even
think he posted last year no yeah i
think he's been taking a break i
wish he would come back because i love
his videos i think he's great me too
uh mysterious obviously had a huge year
yeah her trisha payta series was uh
was it was a big deal it was just a big
deal yeah it was
extremely in-depth i don't think i've
seen
something that in depth in like a while
like
and actually it really brought to light
you know the mr uh riney thing yeah i
wasn't aware of and
really compelling uh case that that on
that one yeah that it was a fab
fabricated accusation
right
um
but you know rick rick's
rick lux the house
whatever rick luck's the house girl
rich lux
i i love rich lux i think he's i think
he's hilarious
but everyone here is uh is great and we
honor them all do you want to do the
honors oh you want me to do it i i feel
like it's kind of awkward if i do it all
right
youtube drama news coverage
ooh mama i'm rooting for you buddy
here we go
the winner is
wow
57
huge majority here
wow
this is shocking
[Music]
death noodles
all right well thank you
definitely thank you so much hey i'm
gonna take can i can i say something i'm
gonna split my award with everyone
because here's the thing i want everyone
to to do more news coverage so we can
just uh to kill keemstar's piece of the
pie [ __ ] them more the more the married
exactly the more the merrier so more
death noodles
i appreciate it though thank you so much
everyone
you're sharing it with all the knowledge
sharing it with all the nominees
everyone i d'angelo so you come back
rich lux
because you're you keep it up girl yeah
uh mr beard i feel like uh he's been uh
his videos are just mind-blowing yeah
he's dope yeah
um scarce a legend
keep it come back come back we missed
you exactly he like comes back for a
while and then he leaves comments
yeah um and then we forget adam adam
mcmahon
that's great mysterious is great so
shout out to all the nominees but def
there's only one winner def noodles by
57 congratulations buddy adam mcintyre
appreciated 17
uh uh and second runner-up d'angelo
wallace who had who by the way 12
and that's with not posting a video and
you know yeah
shout out to all of them congratulations
you buddy you could that that's all
yours should i drink it yeah take a sip
down at all
the dry ice everything am i gonna die if
i do it okay so yeah there's a good
chance all right well i'm really happy
you won you know you were definitely my
vote
well i appreciate it thank you you've
had a big year you know there's been a
lot of growth there's been yeah last
year i think was it was a big year for
you right it was yeah it was a great
year i mean it was uh
i just i i love like i'm obsessed with
like working so as long as i have work
to do
i'm having there's always work to do in
this world yeah exactly yeah so uh yeah
it's great i love it good son of a
[ __ ] are you working with
[Laughter]
are you a one-man show or do you work
with people at this uh i'm mostly like a
one-man show but i am like i have been
like uh trying to like hire people who
can like help me
um
i just haven't found like the right
people yet so
uh but yeah it's still
trying to
run wrong did you drink the dry ice no
it's the water i think i looked away for
a second does it taste like battery acid
water
thank you zach
[Applause]
as you were saying
okay yeah i'm okay
what were you saying uh yeah so that's
pretty much it well yeah
well i'm wishing for another big year
for you next year yeah just keep it up
love your videos watch them all the time
and
thank you i love your insta you got
banned on twitter obviously but your
updates on instagram are great too and i
follow a lot there yeah that's why i've
been posting mostly yeah so keep it up
next category is a nice one best attempt
at murdering your friend
yeah i this one is uh it's a toss-up i
think this is where we've come in the
influencer world i mean this is a
category we have three strong nominees
yeah so let's roll it
best attempt at murdering your friend
david dobrik hitting jeff widdick with
an excavator does this make you happy
[ __ ] all my face [ __ ] off
hold on i don't know how to approach it
obviously i've never been in a situation
like this neither has jeff neither
probably any of us i didn't know
the correct way to go about any of it
the other way would have killed me
nikki and dan felipe putting the dog
down
that wasn't really
man it's so awkward saying the words i
feel like i don't even shut up
bryce hall knocking out foosie too
and my immediate reaction which
obviously wasn't the right reaction was
to just punch this [ __ ]
you know what i'm not even gonna
necessarily say that bryce did the wrong
thing in that moment
yeah i gotta see it a little bit of
self-defense because he was like
yeah touching people not backing up yeah
i mean a punch was was was relatively
justified i would say in that moment
uh boy i mean david dolberg's gonna be
hard to beat
oh yeah yeah uh taking an excavator out
and the into the wilderness camera the
other operating heavy machinery yeah you
gotta love that i mean most people they
have osha they have a license they have
a super safety supervisor david dobrik
takes in a full blown excavator ties his
friend to the end and then only uses one
hand to operate it and holds the camera
other that's he's really trying to kill
jeff he must hate jeff yeah like that's
one thing i don't understand like he has
a nine million dollar mansion right yeah
he can't afford to pay one guy one or
two people yeah once safe
he didn't have a medic not even medic
they had to drive with his head he
describes his head's like falling off
his face like out of his face as they're
driving to the hospital and they're like
don't look don't look in the mirror yeah
don't look but yeah that's crazy yeah
it's great and then you've got the uh
the other family there they just
straight up killed their dog that they
just got like a month ago because uh
he wasn't potty trained or something i
don't know it was uh i think it was
part of like the thing with a kid right
that uh
tried to bite their kid or something
yeah so they're like we're gonna kill
you yeah oh yeah and he said i wanted to
take the dog and back and kill him
myself he wanted to do uh he says old he
mentions old yeller yeah except with
yeah you know the difference is they
love their dog old yeah yep
he had an incurable a fatal disease
the only incurable fatal disease
is your stupidity my friend okay so
well
i believe it's your you're up there
right so best attempt at murdering your
friend drum roll please
big winner 2021 huge category
oh
with uh 70 percent of the vote
it's uh david dobrik no surprises here
hitting chat with an excavator 78
78
well the category was practically made
for him let's be honest basically yeah
yeah
uh and then uh the runners up were uh
the philippines putting down their dog
with 20 and then bryce hall knocking out
fouseytube
yeah that wasn't really a guess attempt
at murder but a good moment nonetheless
yeah well congratulations to david he
had a big year 2021 was a big drama
field year for him yeah actually drama
is kind of even to kind of
really just straight up crimes i would
say for the most oh yeah yeah yeah i'm
pretty sure
if
jeff
if janet jeff had died you would have
gone to manchester united manslaughter
right oh yeah no doubt
no doubt about it yeah actually he would
have been deported too probably eh
because he's here on a
great card you can't do felony at the
time i don't think he had it he was on
on daca now he has it oh he got that
yeah he would have he would have gone to
jail yeah man
yeah and then like what's crazy is
talking to jeff apparently
they just he paid for his medical bills
and then kind of ghosted him so oh yeah
because he
david was like a hair away
from killing a man and ruining his own
life forever yeah and then he you know
narrowly avoided that and then he's like
well cool back to business yep what a
guy love him for that you notice how
they're not hanging out that much
anymore either well of course
yeah
yeah i'm sure jeff has an incredible
amount of resentment
and david uh
he only likes to be surrounded by uh
pristine faces yeah no blemishes no
blemishes
that's not good for the vlog yeah he
used to be beautiful and uh well
you have to be beautiful to be uh in
david's vlog do you think that's mostly
from david that they're not hanging out
because they were after the documentary
came out they were for like jeff was at
his house a bunch of times yeah yeah and
then all of a sudden it kind of like
dropped off like the vlog squad member
still stopped by
jeff's podcast and stuff but
i think they both had a vested interest
i think jeff probably just wanted to uh
heal emotionally david obviously had a
vested interest in rehabilitating his
image and seeing them together yeah and
i'm sure that jeff
holds in a tremendous amount of
resentment and no i don't think david
has any interest in seeing jeff uh he's
obviously
if one thing's been proven throughout
last year is that david is uh
he has uh
he's might well be a a sociopath
and so i think he has no interest in uh
yeah with jeff there
a constant reminder of a you know of
that the
potentially one of the biggest mistakes
of his life yeah yeah hopefully the
biggest was there hopefully you know you
can hopefully it doesn't do anything
yeah yeah hopefully it stops here
we're gonna have a big year next year eh
for the steamies
well
here's a big one
worst midlife crisis
wow
let's what let's look at the nominees
yeah
worst midlife crisis
keemstar
this is gonna be real hard to beat
[Music]
wow
that's hard to be here
man
[Music]
no words needed
the shirt in the pool
[Music]
ryan kavanagh oh it says harvey
weinstein
i mean it's it's understandable to
confuse him
yeah it's ryan kavanaugh just to be
clear not
harvey weinstein harvey weinstein's in
jail
[Music]
wow those fits are just so wild man
look at those fits do we have any shots
of brad the ball
[Music]
kanye
don't play with me
don't play with my children and ain't no
security gonna get in between me and my
children and you ain't gonna gas like me
dana white
[Music]
good it is not your responsibility to
make your wife happy right so just like
it's not my wife's responsibility to
make me happy you've been on a hell of a
journey with me
that's a typically responsibility
right you know
it's healing that needs to happen
absolutely so what happened jaden he
hates her
when jeff bezos has a midlife crisis the
whole world suffers
i want to hear this
shatner's just not down with any of this
[Applause]
some tough competition
well
you know the shoe ends got to be
keemstar and not just because he's a
frequent topic between the two of us but
genuinely as far as midlife cri you got
a a four-year-old man dating you know 18
year old teenagers fresh out of high
school
and then he's too embarrassed he calls
them they're his assistants
i mean my goodness
i'm busted yeah yeah
well what do you think kirk i mean uh i
think keemstar yeah keemstar is probably
at the top of it uh i would also say
uh the will smith and jada stuff
was just really it felt like it was an
onslaught of like they just kept over
sharing stuff about their relationships
and it kept getting crazier and crazier
so
but mostly his wife or mostly jada huh
well it was mostly dated at the
beginning then he put out this uh he had
his uh by like his uh what do you call
it his memoir okay and in his memoir he
had like stuff he talked about being
jealous of tupac and like
having these like uh you know
sexual disorders and yeah
yeah he there was one thing about he
said like because he was sleeping with
so many groupies he would like throw up
instead of orgasming
stuff like that now that's good yeah he
would throw up instead of orgasm that's
what he said on them or privately uh i
don't know he never really explained he
said it was like a psycho
he said it was a psychosomatic
uh reaction
well
yeah
that is an overfear yeah certainly
yeah well worst midlife crisis 2021
you the people have voted
49 percent
the winner is keemstar
of course deserved
well-deserved well they're very well
deserved and this is actually keemstar's
second uh steamy i believe oh he's
sweeping today yeah he he's almost for a
hat trick coming up here yeah uh ryan
cavanaugh was a runner up 29 kanye west
12 percent
yeah
it kind of is going a bit off the rails
too he had a recent one where uh that
was pretty good just the other day ian
where he was like
uh
it's gonna all be legal baby it's all
going to be legal and i'm coming for the
kids or some [ __ ] yep
yeah he's having like his toxic divorce
dad
uh era yeah
it's not never good when the kids are
involved you know yeah
yeah keemstar wow congratulations
keemstar
hey guy stupid [ __ ]
and my my condolences to his uh
his girlfriends
yeah that's gotta be if if
will smith is puking on people instead
of organizing me i can only imagine what
keemstar does oh yeah
can you imagine being in your 40s and
dating somebody who still has braces on
i can't man i really can't that's just
that's a lot especially when you have a
young daughter who's probably closer in
age to the girlfriend yeah than to him a
10 year old fan right away
10 year old 10 year old what okay edp
say that again
uh 10 year old fan right away
whoa
keemstar's not on his way to get a
cupcake or anything is he
[Laughter]
well we're coming up on the last
category this is
okay
this is the big one
there was a certain somebody we excluded
that probably would have taken the sweep
here whose initials are oh yeah start
with t and end with p gotcha
and i don't mean toilet paper yeah i
thought that for a second no yeah go
ahead i'll let you do the honors uh
let's roll see our nominees most
dramatic creator
most dramatic creator last year who won
them
austin mcbroom
who won dan last year ethan klein
wait pause it
hold on
who won last year trisha yeah i wanted
you to say it okay
but she was stoked she was so happy and
she should be this is a great honor yeah
this is the steamies dude she was
thrilled yeah
well you're not here you're nominated
this year so what did i
do let's take a look we'll start it over
sorry i'm starting it over
[Music]
most dramatic creator
austin mcbroom
ethan klein
gabby hannah
james charles
nicardo nicocado avocado
nikita dragon
these are your nominees
all right well let's take a look i mean
gabby hannah was she in a big drama this
year uh yeah she had that whole series
she made like uh 10 videos like the old
jessie smiles thing we're like rehashing
the whole thing with jessie
she made it yeah and they're calling it
okay so she i guess it's been a long
year it's been oh yeah and then even at
the end of the year she had this thing
with perez hilton where she went on
gloria stefan's like facebook show and
got into beef with perez hilton really
yes and tried to rewrite her whole
history well austin mcbroom i wouldn't
call necessarily a dramatic creator
would you
austin mcbroom i mean i
it depends on the situation i think he's
kind of dramatic in the sense that uh
he's he just does huge scams yeah
exactly yeah yeah tana [ __ ] i mean
again i'm not sure nicotto is very
dramatic yeah nikita i'm not super
familiar with her dramas and all that
but okay and then there's me which i
don't know why you guys even nominated
me
you're not familiar with
you were in a drama with nikita were you
not oh yeah that's a small spat twitter
spot nothing serious
in fact i think you've been in a drama
with most of the people gabby i've never
been on a drama with i guess by proxy
with tristan austin never i don't think
i've been in a drama with tana
i was in a little something with nico
nicoto that ended amicably
so i mean what's the big deal
all right go ahead and open it alright
so let's see and the winner is
[Music]
with 33 percent thank god it is
happy happy hannah i was afraid i was
really afraid i was gonna win it this
year wow oh the golden teapot that's
right yeah this is a cute you see
yeah trisha would have been an absolute
chill-in with this yeah wow it's gold
encrusted or
a whole steamy gabby with 33 percent
nicado 30
ethan klein 26
incredible i mean it was close and you
you almost won it was close too close
for comfort
i got to tell you ian correct me if i'm
wrong but at one point you actually were
in the lead yeah well at one point what
does that matter dan i'm just saying
that it was neck and neck yeah
yeah well at one point uh one of the
sperms in your dad's ball sack was uh
swimming faster than yours
but what does it matter because you're
the one that won
right okay okay i see where you were
going thank you
very much took me a second doesn't
matter
well listen
gabby hannah huh congratulations
we gotta get her this
well we reached out for a comment in an
acceptance video and um did you tell her
she won shocking no
i don't i don't think we we told anybody
that they won we just told them if you
were to win would you like to send an
acceptance video i think when you know
it she didn't reply i don't see why she
shouldn't accept this
[Music]
well let's just go ahead maybe now that
she won we'll we'll reach out let her
know
well wow what a year it's been i mean
2022
yeah do we have any spicy dramas that
already happened this year that that
like you know uh been shaping up to be a
good year i mean there's uh i mean
there's been some serious stuff like
with the jack right stuff like he posted
a video right right right it the that
picked up there was a pokeman stuff the
pokeman stuff yeah
right so
um that's what i can and the the britney
stuff that's just the brittany's still
going on so i would say it's a
relatively slow start to the year yeah
but last year was the same thing and
then march came around in march you
think yeah your prediction when all hell
is going to break loose i think so like
i don't know maybe this is a weird
observation or not but like i feel like
people like calm down in the winter and
then things start warming up
and then
you know like become you know that
emotions come out i think that's a real
thing there's studies
that say that people are more violent
and do more crimes
in the summer when it's hot yeah because
they're more active they're going
outside they're getting more
confrontations well we'll we eagerly
wait for it to heat up here yeah wow
what a year it's been
what congratulations to you oh yeah
thank you so much absolutely yeah yeah
man keep it up i appreciate it this is
uh it's great i'm gonna put it in my uh
figure i have a green screen in my thing
so i'm going to figure out a way to put
it in there somehow that what i'm
honored yeah yeah i'm honored no i'm on
it no i'm honest
[Applause]
and i can do that
what do you guys think uh anything else
uh what do we got here
uh nope that's the show
well congratulations to all the winners
i can't say there were any surprises
what were you guys surprised by we
pretty much called every one of those
didn't we yeah pretty much yeah we
thought you were gonna win that last one
yeah i thought i was going to win the
last one
i thought the audience might just troll
you
i thought the audience was definitely
going to vote me in for that one scared
i was my heart was racing
i didn't want that one i was really
shocked by the winner of the worst
awards show though
that one really oh yeah
100 too that's unbelievable that was wow
yeah
out of left field on that one
yeah
well
what can i say what a year thank you all
for watching the second annual steamies
thank you thank you to deaf noodles the
one and only deafnoodles on youtube
on instagram not on twitter not on
twitter i'm banned are you feeling
hopeful that 2022 we're gonna be getting
back on twitter uh yeah i'll eventually
get my twitter account back like why are
you so confident that you're getting
because you always say i'm gonna get it
back where does your confidence come
from i know i know that i didn't do
anything wrong that's the the main
reason why
so
like it's just
it is what it is justice shall prevail
we need to yeah justice shall prevail we
believe in justice here on this show
well thank you everybody for watching
let's look forward to a juicy 2022
together
guys
uh
god bless
oh one good night
and good night okay never mind what are
we gonna say well maybe we should just
um give the audience a heads up
ela is due to have a little brucy in the
next coming days so there is a strong
chance that there are um maybe some
missing episodes yesterday in fact i
will say i'm i'm in i wasn't sure we
would even be doing this yeah no it
really could happen
i don't know what's going but yeah i
mean it could happen very likely this
weekend early next week that we're all
kind of just improvising at this point
with little bruce coming out here pretty
soon here
good night
[Music]